Now let's state the general rule for
creating all the transition clauses.
Recall that a tuple k, l,
k prime, l prime, delta, is valid,
if switching to state qk prime,
writing out the symbol sl prime and
moving into action delta is an option,
given that the machine is currently
in state qk and reading symbol sl.
For every step I, position j, and
invalid transition, k, l,
k prime, l prime, delta,
we include in the formula a clause like
this, the first part tests whether
the truth assignment is such that
the transition rule actually applies.
And the next three rules ensures that
this invalid transition wasn't followed.
This is just the generalization of
the example that we saw earlier.